how how are you and i with a book and a
ted talk and a little and a sign post
you know and a tweet you know on a
linkedin article like how are you and i
gonna completely change the mind of
somebody whose entire incentive
structure
at his company is to drive advice to
benefit his income
we're not fair okay at all
and what we can do is continue with the
movement and chip away
where i mean that business roundtable
making that statement
is a coup for us because it's like i
said we would have been laughed out of
the room
you and i having this conversation on a
public forum would have been the butt of
a joke
in the 80s and 90s but now people listen
to us and go hmm
that's interesting and even though there
are still many many senior executives
who think you and i are stupid idealists
right and and think that the reality of
the world is not how it works that way
this is the profound profound uh uh uh
um
strength of the the understanding of the
infinite game which is it turns out
that we've we've all been coming to work
with it not here but you know
general you know people have been coming
to work with that sense of discomfort
something's not right here like i don't
enjoy work like i should like it's fine
that's how most people describe their
jobs how's work it's fine
fine right uh
and when we try and say something we're
told you don't understand how business
works and they're rich and they're
powerful so we just keep our heads down
and i guess they know
for me what i've learned from this
infinite mindset
they don't know how business works
business is an infinite game
they're playing for the wrong game they
don't know how business works
and that uncomfortable feeling we have
even though we haven't been able to put
words on it
turns out we're onto something and all
we have to do is keep preaching and
preaching and being the leaders we wish
we had
and we will chip away at the system
because we will grow up and to become
the new ceos when they retire and die
and we will take over and we will take
over wall street
when they retire and die like it's it's
a generational thing
i'm not trying to convince somebody i'm
trying to get a new generation of people
now
who will eventually be promoted who will
eventually get jobs who will eventually
apply will eventually
start the companies and build the
companies themselves that in 20 to 30
years from now
capitalism will go back to the type of
capitalism that made america what it is
today
and thomas jefferson owned all the
volumes both volumes of wealth of
nations
that adam smith wrote america is built
on a capitalist ideal that is
not the capitalism we have today but we
can return it
it took 20 or 30 years to get to where
we are now it'll take us 20 or 30 years
to get back to where we need to be